hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well in Section two of
his essay the will to believe William
James is going to engage in some
criticism of another earlier
philosophers argument for the existence
of God and it's called Pascal's wager
after Blaise Pascal the great
mathematician philosopher and would-be
theologian it's found in Pascal's
Ponce's which were a set of notes that
he had accumulated as he was attempting
to write a great work of apologetics so
it comes from a section called in French
the party or the wager and Pascal is
arguing that if we're betting people
then we ought to embrace at least on a
pragmatic level the idea that God exists
and we ought to act accordingly that
it's actually a rational decision to
make the the intellect you might say
conform to the will and to eventually
work ourselves into belief by engaging
in a certain mode of action
interestingly James himself in the
ese the will to believe is taken by many
interpreters as providing yet another
pragmatic style of argument James is in
fact a pragmatist he's one of the people
who embraced that term and so both he
and Paschal are doing somewhat similar
things it's both based on action and its
relationship with belief so why is James
criticizing Pascal's wager first we have
to go over what poss calls wager
actually amounted to and this is not the
totality of that section in his his work
the posses or the thoughts but it's it's
a close enough approximation for this so
Pascal's wager you can think of as
presenting something like a square of
possible options and outcomes and
there's two sides to each of these are
two possibilities one of these is a
factual possibility either God exists or
God does not exist one of those is true
there's really no halfway house in
between existence when it comes to
things like that so you know you could
say well exists in what way or what kind
of God we're not going to worry about
that at this point here's what the human
person the believer or non-believer has
up to them they can act as if God exists
or they can act as if God doesn't exist
so what are the possible outcomes in
this 2x2 grid so let's think about if
you act first of all let's take the God
doesn't exist right if God doesn't exist
and you act as if God does exist then
you're probably missing out on some
pleasures you know you don't get to
sleep in on Sunday mornings or you know
whenever it happens to be that you go to
church or whatever you know would be the
ceremony and there's some moral rules
that you have to follow you don't think
about those in the Ten Commandments
don't steal don't commit adultery you
know but stealing is sometimes
profitable and committing at
tree can be fun don't kill don't bear
false witness all those sorts of things
right well you know you would be doing
those and you're missing out on some
good times as a result but you're not
missing out on that much because you
know human life is finite so even if you
were able to like keep up your pleasures
you're not actually losing too much
same thing with act as if God doesn't
exist if God doesn't exist oh you get to
enjoy yourself and then you die so
you're not beset by the same problems as
religious believers who are willfully
depriving themselves of some of the
pleasures they could be enjoying but you
know he's still not getting that much
more than they are then what if God does
exist
well now we have an infinite reward or
punishment an infinite good or an
infinite evil because according to
Christian doctrine you're either going
to ultimately to heaven in which case
you'll enjoy eternal beatitude that is
happiness and bliss or you're going to
hell in which case you suffer infinite
death eternal death torment whatever
that happens to be and you don't have to
have a clear conception of it whatever
it happens to be it's pretty bad right
as a matter of fact infinitely bad so
whatever good stuff you get as a
compensation like the pleasures you
enjoy in this life far outweighed by the
infinite evil and the compensation for
missing out on those pleasures that you
otherwise could have indulged yourself
in in this life is infinite pay off
beyond pleasure it's bliss now Pascal
says if you are a rational better you
don't know whether God exists or doesn't
exist you don't know where the balls
gonna fall on the roulette table
although the ball has already fallen so
to speak right the cards have already
been dealt you just are gonna find out
whether you pick the right or wrong side
what's the right side to pick for
Paschal it's definitely act as if God
exists because you don't want to take
the chance of that
infinite you know torment you don't want
to take the chance of losing out on that
infinite good just for the sake of some
finite pleasures now plus call says
something that James is going to pick up
on that allows some criticisms to be
made there are other ways to criticize
this argument as well one would be well
you know which God are you talking about
for puska although it has to do with the
actions what do you do if you act as if
God exists he says well you take the
holy water and go to Mass and you know
eventually it'll sort itself out right
so you bless yourself with holy water
when you walk in or things along those
lines and you would presumably partake
in all of the rituals appropriate to not
just a Christian but a Catholic way of
acting as if God exists so James has
three main criticisms of Pascal's wager
here he says that you probably feel that
when religious faith expresses itself
like this in the language of the gaming
table it's put to its last Trump's
surely Pascal's own personal belief in
masses and holy water had far other
Springs and the celebrated page of his
is but an argument for others a last
desperate snapchat a weapon against the
hardness of the unbelieving heart we
feel that a faith in masses and holy
water adopted willfully and cetera et
cetera he's saying that Paschal has some
other passional or volitional sources
for why he thinks that masses in holy
water as opposed to you know Hindu
bhakti as opposed to you know plain
strong or something like that as opposed
to sitting silently in Quaker meeting
until somebody is you know inspired to
speak or whatever whatever other thing
it would be Paschal has some other
attachment
to this and that's gonna lead ultimately
to the third criticism but the second
criticism is this and there's actually a
nice funny joke in there he says we feel
a faith in masses and holy water adopted
willfully after such a mechanical
calculation would lack the inner soul of
a faiths reality and then he goes a
little bit further I think this is funny
myself but in some respect it actually
shows that none of us should be God he
says if we were ourselves in the place
of the deity we should probably take
particular pleasure in cutting off
believers of this pattern from their
infinite reward in other words if you're
only believing in God because you're
looking for the payoff maybe you don't
deserve the payoff then maybe you're
just like as Ansem said and in one of
his treatises of the day stimula to deny
boost that you know people like that are
basically mercenaries right so you know
Sherwood a truly infinite and good God
cut such people off maybe not would we
yes because we think if there's
something repugnant about making your
belief a set of payoffs on a matrix the
third criticism that James is going to
make is particularly interesting and it
connects us back to this essay and to
this notion about options he says that
it's evidence unless there is some
pre-existing tendency which he thinks
that that Pascal has to believe in
masses in holy water the option offered
to the will by Pascal is not a living
option so he says certainly no Turk by
the sea means of Muslim ever took two
masses and holy water on its account and
even to us Protestants these means of
salvation seems such foregone
impossibilities that Pascal's logic
invoked for them especially leaves us
unmoved as well might the Mahdi write to
us saying I
the expected one whom God has created in
his full jhin's you shall be infinitely
happy if you've confessed me otherwise
you'll be cut off but from the light of
the Sun way then your infinite gain if I
am genuine against your finite sacrifice
if I am NOT his logic would be that of
Pascal but he would vainly use it on us
why the hypothesis he offers us is dead
no tendency to act on it exists to any
degree and so you know we might say well
the world is divided up then into those
who you know can accept masses and holy
water and those who can't they're there
the Catholics perhaps the Orthodox as
well and you know oriental Orthodox and
that everybody else that's not going to
work for them but even among Catholics
that might not work either
you know if your only experience with
masses is it's this place that everybody
goes to mumble song Hawking a meal and
stand up at the right time and every
once in a while you know towards the end
you get a wafer and a little bit of a
drink and you have no conception of
what's actually going on probably not
going to be a live option right there
has to be something there in order to
give that weight so this isn't a proof
in the sense that Paschal means it to be
that's James criticism because it's got
no you could say gripping points in our
hearts or our passional and volitional
nature whereas it did for Paschal and it
did for most of the other people that he
is writing to in his own time but no
longer works in the present the way that
Paschal intended it to do
you